ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dillon show I want to explain the
backdrop for a minute we are in our new
studio in New York we have two Studios
um so that we never have to miss a video
episode of the podcast on our New York
City background is on its way but we
wanted to get an episode out for you uh
this week and we we're we're hoping that
the background is going to arrive but
we're dealing with all kinds of
characters uh people from the
Netherworld uh dark people that you know
uh you know they exist uh at the bottoms
of stairwells and there can only be
contacted by certain means and you know
they're doing it though it's going to be
great but you know we are
we are using uh the the the people of
the earth as you call them right the
little kind of you know they burrow into
things and under things and many of them
are just there and then we're using them
to get to get the you know and it's
coming so don't but this is not the
permanent background it's a black
curtain
um and sag is on strike and I support
and we're on YouTube right now and I'm
gay YouTube I'm a gay person I'm gay I'm
a homosexual gay man on YouTube in a
very
heterosexual
patriarchal world of people and what oh
what a horrible thing for me to have
lived through that being gay and I'm so
happy I can be gay on YouTube be gay man
on YouTube homosexual gay on YouTube and
and it held me back in life dealing with
that and I still I stole a lot and that
was they were also not great but I was
trying to buy drugs but it was hard so
to have The Bravery to be gay on YouTube
gay
to be gay on YouTube and so and to
support the Ukraine unquest I don't even
know I don't question it at all every
dollar I make half of it I I should go
to the Ukraine because I'm gay
YouTube on being gay in the Ukraine
which is something I would love to I
would love to be gay in the Ukraine if I
could and the only way I can is if they
win that [__]
so that's all I wanted to say starting
off the show I love the new Little
Mermaid it's not black enough
to be honest with you it's not black
enough the new Little Mermaid it's
actually not I want it to be even
Blacker
and and I she has a lovely voice that
girl that's singing it's beautiful
um but I think it could have even went
you know to where it's almost
uncomfortable for everyone and that's
what I wanted
um but that's all I have to say to
because I'm here now on YouTube
and I'm and I and I
and I support Fran Drescher to the the
person who's doing this writer strike I
do and the SAG she's the in in the the
union that I'm in the Screen Actors
killed
Fran Drescher who if you remember it was
in a show called The Nanny and she was
the star of the show she was the nanny
and she is now the president of the
Screen Actors guilt and it's a great
Injustice what's happening right now and
I'm a little disappointed that Americans
don't care
about the the the trouble that actors
and writers are having
not making any money
Americans are like hey they're they're
they're of the attitude it's like hey
[__] you
and all you make is crap that we don't
want to watch
but that's not true
there's a few things that you like that
could go away if this doesn't get
rectified
there are those big budget Marvel movies
you all like
you Slumber into the theater like I
heard a cattle and buy a bucket of soda
with your kids and eat little hot dog
Donuts they're going away hey that's
going away
it's not just succession
some of the things you like or go the
movies where cats talk to each other you
like that that's out too all the films
were cats and dogs speak
because Americans like well they like
that they like when cats and dogs speak
to each other because they can in real
life but in the movies they can and
people like it so some of those things
in America and they like the movies of
what is that the Fast and Furious where
they keep stealing all the car they keep
taking cars every year in some other
desert and that can go away
it's not just the faggedy things that
you're you know
brother-in-law watches on the BBC which
is not affected by the it but there's
some actual real explosions that may not
happen because of the strikes you should
you should get mad at this and I you
know I famously here see everyone's
point with the strike I do
because I I think people should get paid
fairly but then I look at what's
happening and I look
let's take a look at Snow White
Snow White is a movie that is coming out
now
it is a Disney film it is it should be a
hit
Snow White who could have more name
recognition
than Snow White everybody knows what
Snow White is about it is about uh a
woman or a girl
who is tempted with a witch who gives
her an apple is that correct that is
correct
after that I don't but it's there's a
wolf too but everyone knows about it
it's big
and it should just these things these
remakes should just kill there should be
no it should be on if you don't [__]
this stuff up it should be easy Snow
White get a wolf
get a [__]
get a witch you're done get a prince
probably
no snow white you would think this would
be the perfect time to employ little
people not using the other m word I'm on
YouTube and I'm gay but I'm using the
word little peep now you would think
these are this is seven little actors
can work
seven little actors can now work you
would think right wrong
wrong
Disney's live-action snow white Under
Fire for replacing Seven Dwarfs with
quote magical creatures of all sizes and
genders
this again was the one opportunity for
little people to have their moment in
the sun other than that role on Game of
Thrones that he killed Peter Dinklage
but now seven people get to have
a potential shot and what do they do get
make that make that screen bigger look
at this freak show
that they have first of all these are
not dwarfs there's only one dwarf
the rest of them look unkempt they look
homeless they look diseased this you
could have accomplished this by going to
Seattle and grabbing seven heroin
addicts that were living under a [__]
bridge this is scary this does not look
like something kids would like you
should have little cherubic like people
that's what dwarfs are they're tiny
somewhat chubby hearty hard-working
people this is like a [__]
unemployment line of scum
every person here I couldn't
what are they wearing what do they dress
what is that why are you destroying
everything this is so easy to not [__]
up
you could have black little people
there's nothing wrong with that get all
the little people of all the races but
they need to be little why are you why
are you why is the guy in the Middle
with long hair being hired what group is
he in
let me see why they're doing it because
they're trying to modernize these movies
they're destroying everything and this
is one of the reasons it's hard to get
people to care about this strike because
they have turned on the business they
don't enjoy the things that are being
made anymore
they don't care
and if if you don't get them to care
you lose that popular support let's find
out
okay quote literally no offense to
anyone but I was a little taken back
when they were very proud
to make this bigger when they were very
proud to cast a Latina actress is Snow
White which by the way it's fine that's
fine no one cares okay
but you're still telling the story of
Snow White and the Seven Dwarfs he said
in January 2022. I don't know who's
saying that
um
you're Progressive in one way but then
you're still making that [__]
backward story about seven dwarfs living
in a cave together what the [__] are you
doing man have I done nothing to advance
the cause for my soapbox I guess I'm not
loud enough
in response Disney said it was taking
quote a different approach to avoid
reinforcing well it's about
Christ almighty so find out who said
that because they ruined the whole
[__] movie
one guy said if somebody had a problem
with that they were making a movie with
seven by the way what I don't even
understand the negative stereotypes
about dwarfs in the movie
that they work hard
first of all if you remember the dwarfs
were not painted as one thing there was
sleepy happy
uh there was a few of them jewie there
were a few different dwarfs and I forget
what they did and who they were but they
each had a specific personality and a
specific thing that they did nobody was
saying that like all the dwarfs are one
thing is it but all that they they were
just they worked hard right that was
what we knew them for that they were
workers why is that such a bad idea why
is that a what what stereotype is being
reinforced that they live in a cave
I'm I'm so curious
oh this is Peter Dinklage
you know I gotta be honest I'm not happy
about this and I don't want to go to war
with him but it's really like
what if there was a
if there was a uh if there was a Disney
film
called Snow White and the fat [__]
if there was no I'm saying if there was
I'm not saying there is if there was and
it was seven fat [__] that were like
myself kind of loud and vicious
number one better movie number two why
would I comply wouldn't complain about
like what is he complaining about does
Peter Dinklage not like that there are
dwarfs does he not want them to
I don't know I'm confused man he doesn't
like the portrayal of the disability in
the what's the disability well as what
though
this is what I'm trying to understand
and maybe he could help me understand
this because maybe
I'm not understanding why he's mad and
maybe he's mad for a very legitimate
reason all I'm understanding is that
there are people that are little maybe
they don't like the word dwarf but they
are littler than other people right and
Snow White befriends them right
what's the problem
uh I'm I mean I don't under can you
articulate why he's upset if I were
guessing maybe he doesn't want his his
culture to be a Disney character
dwarf culture
I just here's the thing man then don't
make it
or Disney's he's got to tell him [__]
you someone's gonna tell him [__] you
Peter hey [__] you
you know how many little like he's
taking here's what Peter Dinklage is
doing he's taking the food out of a
little woke mouth of those little mouse
that could be eating Peter Dinklage is
stealing food out of their mouth there's
seven here's what Peter Dinklage is
saying I'm the only one that can be
famous just me sorry everybody we're
shutting that down you know how I was a
dwarf in Game of Thrones that's cool
everyone else were closing the little
Bridge the little bridge is going up and
no one can cross over it now because I'm
already rich
so now there's seven scumbags
that are gonna be in this movie when
there were seven actors that have
probably been working their asses off
this is the [__]
like I would like to play the Cheshire
Cat that's like a Disney role for me
that I'd love to play because it smokes
and it's it's kind of nasty and but and
you can tell it's like
it's like just it's like it it like
cares about what's going on you know
like it's kind of cognizant of what's
Happening yeah I like to Cheshire Cat
it's it so this would be my role
this should be my role this is what I
would like to do if I was in if I was
involved if Bob Iger called me today
if you called me today probably try to
get me to kill Fran Thrasher but if you
called me today he'd be like he'd give
Ray comp a gun they'd be like Bob Iger
hands ray compagoney goes Do the Right
Thing Ray
what what do it do the right thing
he's causing all kinds of problems Ray
but to the Cheshire Cat is a role for me
where I would go God damn it I want to
be in that we're we're getting
ridiculous man
so now we have Snow White and the Seven
homeless people
look at that if I saw
that crew
I would go nuts
they're going to destroy the company Bob
Iger is a good CEO he cannot let this
happen
they're going to destroy it now the
little mermaid she was a great talent
she had a great voice
but every one of her sisters was a
different race it was like weird like
one was like a Romanian Gypsy and the
other one it's like it didn't make any
sense
so a lot of this stuff by its very
nature doesn't make sense to anybody
we don't get it
John just saying that it was a it's a
real issue
what's happening right now
with the strike now get up Fran Drescher
like what what is I because I am on
strike now
I am I and I want to show up to the
picket lines
and I want to show this support because
I am striking I won't work right now
unless I'm paid and I have some of my
own
demands that are outside of the strike
I'm going rogue
this is a French restaurant the other
day giving a speech about the strike yes
let's see and I want to see it
cannot change the business model here we
go now by the way what's great about her
they're all acting all the time this is
the most I agree with a lot of what they
want some of it I think is unrealistic
the studios will not budge on AI and you
know maybe not the size of writer's
rooms I do think they'll pay them more I
do think the residuals they'll come to
the table on that
but here's why it's the most
insufferable strike in the world
everyone is acting like when air traffic
controllers go on strike they're not
acting
you know these I mean there's a strike
every other day here in New York there's
an inflatable rent a rat some unions
picketing the local whatever they got
the signs the reason this strike is very
uh it's disgusting to people in
grotesque is because all the people in
it are at like when Ron perelliman was
like Ron promo you know him the guy who
plays a Hellboy and all that other stuff
he's like because supposedly it leaked
out that a studio had said we're we're
just gonna let them lose their houses
we're gonna we're gonna bleed them out
we're gonna let these writers and these
and on my patreon I talk a lot more
about this in a little bit of detail but
he goes basically we're going to let
them die and they lose her so now Ron
Perlman came back and he's like there's
a lot of way to lose your [__] house
brother like he did like a thing where
he's like there's a lot of way to
there's a lot of ways to lose your house
basically a threat going there's a lot
of ways to lose your house like maybe
I'll burn it down maybe I'll kill you
but he's an actor he's not doing
anything he's kind of a puss he's an
actor no offense he could probably kill
me but he's not burning down Bob iger's
house you you it's just not what he is
so the they're all doing [__] like that
they're all dude they're all gonna go
like above there's a there's a lot of
ways to lose a house
don't you don't wanna it's like you're
not the thing you pretend to be just
focus in and try to get a good deal
hammered out she's also losing her mind
no remember we like and I respect Fran
Drescher
um but these people have not acted in a
while and it shows let's go to Fran
changed and not expect the contract to
change too
we're not going to keep doing
incremental changes on a contract that
no longer honors what is happening right
now with this business model that was
foisted upon us can someone write this
for her by the way
can someone can someone stop it can
someone write this down for her because
she's looks like erratic and she doesn't
know what's going on and this is not a
good communication strategy I understood
this is the way that they think actors
they're all like it's got to be all over
the base she's like the business model
is cheap
but it's like you get just let's let's
hammer out points couple of points
couple of key points point one point two
point three point four not this I'm all
over the place I'm screaming and yelling
she looks like she's about to break out
in a song
it's like you gotta you know you gotta
just a little composure goes a long way
and I say that as a member of seg who is
striking who should be heard I I have a
strike platform and it's controversial
and my strike plan and a lot of people
aren't gonna like it my strike platform
is give the studios 90 of what they want
let's take ten percent and many people
do not like that but I say give the
studios 90 I uh let's take ten let's
take ten and that has been defeated I
have been called a scab I have been
called a bootlicker for billionaires
because I have just suggested it was a
mild suggestion giving the studios 90 of
what they want
taking the lowest earning members of sag
and putting them in not a slave program
but a like an indentured servant kind of
working maybe like a mentorship thing
and of course I have been attacked for
that
but
no it's at the end of the day the
Hollywood and the Machine is going to
shrink now it has to there's 600 shows
nobody's watching a lot of them there's
a lot of people trying to make a living
as an actor or a writer it's not
sustainable shows like mine cost a lot
less to produce than these shows we have
more people watching this than a lot of
the shows that are being produced by
streamers for millions and millions and
millions of dollars long term the
sustainability of the business model is
being called into question and of course
the streamers are being shitty to
writers and actors they always have been
um and let's see how much leverage the
writers and actors have I'd like to see
them hammer out a good deal I've
offered to kind of go in and negotiate
but they're not giving up on AIS
if every industry in the world is using
AI Hollywood's not going to take a moral
stand this is the business that rape
children and through women uh into the
fire pits when they spoke up about
anything except a couple years ago
they're not going to be the ones to
think of moral stand about AI like
they're not going to be like well you
know we don't we care about humans and
we don't want to displace any human
beings now they're trying to accelerate
AI so much that they never have to see
another actor and writer again
and I'm sure they would love that
um so so you'll you'll have to figure
out somewhere
that the business that we can live
and people that are working in this
business that where their labor is
getting rewarded in a way that they can
feel comfortable with that's the serious
angle of it but there are things you're
not going to win on these certain that
you can't keep ruining
everything with this crap
where you're hiring
People based on race sexuality gender
and not level of talent and I'm not
saying you can't find both
but if you're going to do this thing
where you're going to remake movies so
that their morality Tales where people
can learn lessons they're just [__]
not gonna watch them you're not they're
not gonna care
do you know who is Snow White by the way
do you know who's to do Snow White
Dylan Mulvaney
Dylan Mulvaney is Snow White
because nobody learns nobody learns a
lesson Dylan Mulvaney is coming as snow
white with the seven magical gender
creatures
she's coming to a screen near you let's
finish up with Fran she looks very angry
she's got to look the thing is you gotta
look a little cooler start you gotta I
feel like you gotta turn it down it's
it's it's too much if I I would say cut
cut
too much just take a little less a
little Fran no we get it
we understand you you gotta people are
yelling at you because you took a photo
with Kim Kardashian in Italy and people
don't think you're you don't think
you're in the cause but we just you we
just need you to tone it down a little
bit and get a hair brush continue
is it
that's right we stand tall that's right
you have to wake up and smell the coffee
I like that one coffee
she had to find a way to get the word
coffee in there yeah maybe she'll use
water too the water sigh
the coffee you better smell the coffee
we're on the water yeah
87 of people in Sag make less than 26
000 a year that cannot even qualify for
health insurance twenty six thousand is
the SAG minimum to qualify for health
insurance there's so much inequality in
the entertainment business right
you know even though it's quote a
progressive and liberal business it's an
insane amount of inequality and uh they
gotta figure something out but it's also
a tough business because who's really in
it how much do you have to do to be in
the [__] business right you can't
just show up and say I'm a writer I'm an
actor I'm a comedian it takes years of
hard work unpaid you got to figure it
out you hop from gig to Gig to Gig to
carve out a career it's not a regular
business it doesn't operate like that
it's not a job creation business their
their job is not to create jobs for
people their job is to find the most
talented people that are trying to do
this and give them opportunities or that
was their job and that should still be
their job I support
everyone involved here I support sag I
support the wga I support uh Big Daddy
zaz David zazlov I support Bobby Iger
over at Disney I support Ted surrandos
at Netflix call me I support every all
the CEOs I support the writers and the
CEOs because you know what we're all
human beings
we're a human being it doesn't matter if
you make a billion dollars or a ten
dollars
we all bleed red blood so I can't it's
hard for me to choose
between
the people that have
the all the billionaires and the people
that I personally know in my own life I
don't really like
but I I agree with the writers and in in
theory I just don't have to see them or
talk to them
because now they're alternative stand up
God is that a mess
so shout out to Big Daddy's as I I
support you you're gonna have to fault
these streamers gonna have to fold a
little bit but I like what they're doing
in the moment because it's like nobody
wants to see anybody fold quickly I
think there should be a long strike with
a lot of violence I think the violence
should go both ways I think there should
be people getting I think people like
Fran Drescher should walk around armed
security I think there should be a lot
of egg throwing and pies I think there
should be like real like blood on the
street I think there should be Lamb's
Blood on the door I think that's good
now I'm not advocating for anything I'm
not telling anyone to do it strictly as
someone who's watching this it would be
nice to see a very Hollywood stripe like
make let's make it a Hollywood strike
let's make it what the movies aren't fun
and watchable I that's what I would hope
that's what I would hope that's all like
is there a version of Fran Drescher that
smacks Big Daddy's ass in the face
did she spit it Bob Iger and this bag
does Bob Iger just [__] go at her
you know I don't know how it works folks
I'm just saying that's my goal my goal
is that uh it is very watched and then
hopefully it ends the pole dancing
convention has left Florida Ronda
Sanchez who I think is a little bit of a
hysteric
um about the G LGB LGB LSD lgbtqia2
stuff I think he's a little bit of a
hysteric although I do and I've talked
about many times and I think the LGBT
whatever Community they're also losing
their minds now and they're it's a big
tent now and it's they're inviting a lot
of people in but
this was sad to me because you know that
I
am a fan of
um you know I like
reasonable
people
rational people
con
moves the 2024 convention away from
Florida
citing drag ban and anti-lgbtq
laws
polkon
a popular pole dancing convention has
decided to move its 2024 convention out
of Florida
citing the state's
anti-lgbtq laws
let's get to the article here
in an interview with Insider Colleen
jolly
the seat no way that's her name but the
CEO and owner of polkon
said she thought she'd hope to hold the
convention in Orlando due to the size of
the pole Community there
keeping the convention inclusive for
lgbtq plus attendees meant moving it she
said quote unfortunately a growing
number of states are making these really
broad laws in the name of protecting
children but they're not protecting
children at all they're just about
controlling and harming Transit queer
folks Jolly told Insider the convention
needs to be moved because it's small
contingent of its attendees are under 18
years old
the 1300 person event typically sells
less than 10 tickets to miners
accompanied by their parents so what
they're there's here's the deal
the idea that Florida is trying to make
itself a state where miners cannot pole
dance
is insane
it's no it's frankly and disgusting
I my because it is a sport
pole dancing it's an art
my cousin and her children visited my
Hampton's estate recently it's not an
estate it is compared to you unless
you're someone you know here's the point
my cousin and her children were at my
house the first thing I asked and I
forget their age is seven or eight or
whatever who cares sweet kids first
thing I asked are they pole dancing
are they pulled it no it's true are they
pole dancing
because it is a great number one it's
exercise so many of these kids are fat
get them on the pole
get him on the pole young so Florida is
trying to make itself a state that does
not welcome families
who want to attend polcon
families of people
usually here's the deal despite that
because the Florida law prohibits
children from attending adult live
performances which includes drag shows
and some pole dancers perform a clothing
that does not match their gender
assigned at Birth so if you want
to take your children
to see
pole dancing drag queens in Florida
you're not allowed to do it
and that's saddens me
if you want to take your children
to Florida and instead of going to
Disney World
you want to take them to polecon so they
can watch pole dancing and maybe learn
to be a pole dancer
what if your child is a drag pole dancer
this is people are born the way they're
born what if your child
is a 10 year old who comes to you and
says I am a drag queen and you go I
support you and you go hold on
I am also a pole dancer
and I want to go to polcon in Florida
where I can dress and drag and dance on
a pole
with my friends
I want to dance on a pole with my
friends in Drag
and if you're a parent
you have to look at your child and go
honey yes
for Christmas this year
right after we get home from Mass
I will buy two tickets to polcon
so that me or three will bring your
father and we'll all go down together
and your father will will watch you pole
dance
because this is crazy
this is a big thing for a lot of
families
this might be the new Disney World in 20
years in our country
there might be more people going to
polcon
maintains that parents should make the
decisions for their children for which
showcases and workshops to attend during
polecon right
Charlie wrote in the blog post
discussing the decision to move the
convention this is not about drag it
never was it's like here's the deal if
you take your kids to pulcon you have to
decide what is important for them to see
and what's not
some performances highlight black and
Latino online performer uh latinx
performers
While others have performers from the
lgbtq plus Community other showcases are
specifically for younger attendees to
perform at other showcases are
perform at so that's when that's for the
kids who want to do pole dancing
I mean if you're a cisgender straight
person you're probably not paying
attention to these laws because you know
I mean listen here's the reality it's
one of those there but for the grace of
God go I things
first they came for kids who are pole
dancing
and you know what I mean and then what's
next
the reason I have this horror Club I do
think DeSantis is wants to make the
country into a Christian theocracy which
I'm sure some people love
uh that idea of course those people rape
more children than anyone that being
said you know the Catholic church that
we'd be closing down those
um that being said this is insane who is
right who
is taking children to a pole dancing
convention in Florida
it's the craziest thing I've ever heard
and I read this article I'm like this is
[__] uh a mad house
so I do think
um
this does not help the case
of anyone I was reading this and they're
like to scientist's laws or targeting
and then I read it and I'm like oh it's
a pull it's pulled it it's like people
that want their children to pole dance
are apparently
upset about it about about it I'm not
saying well I don't know if you should
ban that I think it's a bad idea
for kids to start tinkering with puberty
it's a very bad idea
should it be banned in all cases I don't
know there's probably some extreme cases
um
but I you know again I just think this
is funny that the example being used is
a pole dancing convention in Florida
where people are taking their children
to uh pole dancing in Florida
Robert De Niro's grandson and I touched
on this in the patreon very sad died uh
by taking
um a pill that was a percocet and then
it had fentanyl in it now they're saying
that fentanyls and 90 of drugs in New
York City right now it's crazy he was
sold this drug by a 20 year old girl
named Haley what Sophia Haley marks
Sophia Haley marks called the Percocet
princess we cannot find one photo of her
online here is my conspiracy theory I
think she might be the daughter of
somebody wealthy could that be
is that possible
Percocet princess who allegedly sold
Robert De Niro's grandson drugs that led
to his suspected overdose warned him
literally I don't want to kill you
that's what she said
but then she sold them the fentanyl lace
pills she was being held with that bail
on federal narcotics charges in
Manhattan after selling fake oxycodone
and Xanax with fentanyl in them to
Leonardo De Niro Rodriguez 19 R.I.P he
did not make it
very sad
um Rodriguez first texted Marx on June
30th asking him to buy quote 30s blue
counterfeit oxycodone stand with the
number and she allegedly replied that
they are potentially dangerous
do you really need them
Marx replied according to the criminal
complaint I don't want to kill you
I don't like serving you because they're
not script
meaning not prescription grade
but she served him anyway
and now sadly tragically he died
and uh this is one of those stories that
you know
makes you really think that um you know
if you need if you're out there and
you're struggling with drugs you got to
get help because there's too much
[__] on the street right now that can
kill you
and not over a long period of time we're
talking pretty instantaneously you take
one Percocet
I used to take Percocet and I never
thought and I never felt that I was in
danger from taking Percocet I thought it
was just a fun way to start a morning
and it's a good way to kind of get into
the day you drive to work
you scratch a little bit you get an itch
but you know Percocet uh to me was never
like oh you're gonna die Vicodin
was never like oh you're gonna drop dead
Oxys are a different story
certainly oxies that are laced with
fentanyl are a different story
a lot of kids right now are taking very
severe and serious drugs
and dropping dead and it's [__] very
sad and I don't know what's gonna happen
to this chick
I don't know what's gonna happen to her
but she's probably gonna she's gonna
have to go to jail for a long time
could have to go to jail but I don't
know if that's gonna happen in this
state
they might put her right back out on the
street
but we talked about on the on the bonus
episode like
what would they do in Singapore
how would they handle it
they would hang her in Singapore
they would hang her
and I'm not saying that that should
happen but
that's interesting if you if you wanted
to clean up Society like really quickly
interesting that's all I'm saying
interesting cocaine speaking of drugs
they found cocaine in the white house a
couple of weeks ago or about a week ago
and
it's it's one thousand percent
Hunters there's no way it's not high
there's zero way it's not Hunter Biden's
Coke Zero
look at Hunter Biden
get the video up of him on the White
House he's on a balcony and he does what
every cokehead does who's like sweating
and they don't quite know what to do
with their hands he's a little Manic and
he he puts his hand through his hair
he's he's still actively using try I'm
gonna go out there and say it I have no
proof of this but it doesn't matter
Hunter Biden is still using drugs
let's look at the Mr sober right here so
this is an event at the White House
where Hunter Biden I'm telling you right
now he's high on cocaine you don't have
to believe me
[Music]
high on cocaine he adjusts his nose
right there too you see that yes because
he's doing cocaine
and they know Jill knows
and there's another get it there's
another video of him as well like look
here he is yeah there he is
he's still there he is there he goes
yeah yeah he's good now where's he going
where's he going where's he off to
where is he going okay I'll see you
later then he goes with the wife and now
he's out where is he going the party's
on the deck right there right isn't that
isn't that where the party is where's he
going why is he leaving his face entire
family including the president and the
first lady are standing on that balcony
the party's on the balcony Hunty baby
where's he off to
could I guess
he's still on drugs and this is uh
unfortunate
this is unfair he probably knows that uh
Percocet princess
she's probably on his laptop
um but no there's there's no way he's
not and by the way I would also be on
drugs if we were trying to present my
father
who's riddled with dementia as an
appropriate candidate for the pre I mean
it's great you got to think about he
never I mean the level of fraud you have
to engage in forget politics to just
pretend that Joe Biden is a functioning
adult
the level of censorship you have to
engage in is North Korean Draconian
censorship
bottom up top down everybody's got to be
silenced you got to go at everybody
random comedians slash somebody here
demonetize age gate it make people sign
in you gotta really chip away
at people's free expression
because this is a guy that's clearly
you know have it in some state of
cognitive decline
and his son is there doing cocaine and
Jill doesn't look happy
Jill doesn't know what's going on
and Hunter is fiddling with his name if
I was 100 I would never touch my nose
just because I even if I had an itch I
would know the implication the
implication is is bad
and I wouldn't leave anywhere if
everybody was on the balcony with the
kids I would stay on the balcony with
the guy would not leave
because I was an addict it took me years
and years and years to get over that
when people look at you where you going
how have you been you know you're an
addict when for Christmas instead of
getting cash you start to get gift cards
gift cards mean that your family thinks
you're a junkie
now maybe not anymore because P it's
more digital and those are more common
but back then they were not as common
it was the the first generation of gift
cards to come out and everybody's like
oh Timmy's having problems give him a
gift card you can go buy a CD at the
wall
here's the gift card to Sam goody
and of course we'd use them to cut Coke
up you know we ain't gonna stop us
but
it takes a long time after you've
reestablished yourself to
gain the trust back of people
now imagine you would document that
every bad thing you had ever done on a
laptop every hooker you ever fought with
a gun to her head driving you know at
crazy speeds whatever he's whatever he's
documented
on his uh laptop okay
he will never in his lifetime in 10
lifetimes he will never be trusted again
this is a man who hooked up with his
dead brother's ex
he will never be trusted again this will
never happen never ever ever ever ever
he knows that
he knows he'll never get it back the
trust he will know he will be and it's
unfortunate but he'll be looked at as
some type of crackhead forever so
someone like that in his situation it
seems like
you know
the motivation for them to stop is is
low
because he knows it's hard to get it
back
and he knows whatever scams they were
running with burisma that Energy company
in the Ukraine
they can't do that anymore everything's
out in the open
he knows that
speaking of the Ukraine and Russia we're
now sending cluster bombs
we're sending cluster bombs to the
Ukraine this is a good idea
cluster bombs cluster bombs to the
Ukraine
um Russia will also use cluster bombs by
the way Vladimir Putin warned on Sunday
that Moscow has quote sufficient
reserves of its own cluster munitions
tension yeah
we'll sum it up for you
we do not want this Ward and we are
scared
the Russia Ukraine war is the defense
department sag after strike they do not
want it to end they're not coming to the
table they don't care they're upping the
ante here's cluster bombs they know
Russia's got clustered by as long as
people are dying and people are building
weapons they win that's all they're
concerned about the minute things start
to look like they could be moving in a
direction of Peace we will stop that we
will get in the way of that big time
um there's absolutely we have zero
interest in that Ukraine could use an
increasing number of cluster bombs as
its stockpiles of conventional shells
run low
as it looks so Ukraine is no longer
winning the war for while they were now
they are not
you know Putin goes we have our own
cluster munitions
you know if they do something we're
going to do something if they do it
we'll do it
and this is going to be a failed State
it's probably going to be a frozen
conflict meaning like nobody actually
has a decisive Victory hard to win the
war hard to win the piece
and it just becomes a perpetually
dysfunctional state
and the war kind of goes on and it sucks
up time and resources until I guess one
of those governments is potentially
overthrown and somebody comes in there I
I don't know
I don't know but I just think that
it's just it's it's funny now because we
started this just like covid we were
like two weeks we'll stop the spread
we'll slow it it's fine we started this
going like yeah well we're supporting
the Ukraine
they were invaded by a hostile country
which is true absolutely true
and now we're like let's give them Jets
let's give them cluster bombs let's get
it let's get it going over there
let's get it going and um
it's unfortunate
it's unfortunate and uh
I just I would say
um that I no longer have a like I no
longer I'm not gonna keep bringing it up
I will just let whatever's gonna go down
over there it's just gonna go down and
it's not I'm not gonna Focus too much
time and attention on it
um because it's it's actually supposed
to go away you're not supposed to think
about it the goal is to just it's to be
put away and it's just that thing over
there that happens where we give them
all the money and the weapons uh to and
there's more death happening but we
can't think about it we've got our own
issues like the uh sag strike
so we got to focus on things that matter
like are the dwarves and Snow White
being objectified
um and just keep giving cluster bombs
over to the Ukraine uh check drudge I
wanted to talk about something on drudge
too uh that is uh Just Happening summer
is is uh is getting hotter
right now I mean I think the temperature
in Vegas when I'm gonna be there on
Saturday
for the uh win The Encore Theater at the
win it's gonna be 115 degrees
how [__] insane is that
Vegas this is one of the hottest Summers
ever how are people coping with this
heat
how is it happening
Heat Wave reaching right there max
strength 128 degrees Peak
this is insane
the energy grids of these states are
being pushed to the limits and I don't
know if
they're going to fail or not
it's interesting
to kind of see if an energy grid fails
you're looking at severe problems
you're looking at a lot of people losing
their lives
Death Valley people are still going to
be tourists in Death Valley California
it's like the hottest place on Earth I
think one year they got it it's like 128
degrees it's just an arid hellscape the
only thing that survives there is a
tarantulas and lizards it's a very very
hot part of California and
people are still going they're flocking
there for a tourism
because it's inexpensive
it's cheap people go short rather I'd
rather die
climate change gawking thrives as
tourists flock to Death Valley with
temperatures at 128 degrees so by the
way this is what I talk about disaster
tourism literally this is something I
talked about was going to happen I said
this was going to happen people are
finding the fun in in the decaying
planet and this is kind of cool
it is kind of fun
it is fun to go out and see like
how bad it's getting and everybody is
smiling look at that make that video big
she's smiling they're happy
that's fun look it's 133 degrees smile
that's fun ladies and gentlemen so many
people are having problems right now
illegally with legality it's a litigious
society and you have to sue
you have to Sue and you have to sue
others that have hurt you maimed you in
any way you have to sue them in their
face
call them and sue them sue them right
now soothe them till they're dead
wake up every day and call a lawyer and
Sue
it's the only way to really feel fully
American is to be in a law I know
several people in lawsuits right now and
they feel great
sue them
and you know well you go oh well I don't
know how to sue people yeah I did it's
called Morgan and Morgan it's a law firm
it's the biggest personal injury law
firm in the [__] world
Morgan and Morgan
it's called suing people that [__] you
up
you don't take it lying down
if you fall
if you you're if you fall you were
tripped
if you slip
it was done to you
if you stumble that somebody else baby
and they need to pay
if someone hits you with their car
it's intentional
you need to get them go get him go get
him good go get him good with Morgan and
Morgan if you were ever injured
check out Morgan and Morgan their fee is
free unless they win for more
information
go to forthepeople.com Tim or dial pound
law pound 529 that's forthepeople.com
Timber dial pound law at 529 for the
people.com Tim you know why because
they're not gonna get away with it this
time
no more say a prayer no more well we're
not that Hurt No More it could have been
worse no more we'll do better next time
get them now
call the lawyers
light them on fire drag them to court
drag their ass to court now sue them sue
the [__] out of them
that's what you do
oh your wife goes well it actually could
have been a lot worse shut the [__] up
you stupid [__]
we're suing them every day until we die
go to forthepeople.com Tim and dial
pound Lots pound 529 this is a paid
advertisement so many online e-commerce
businesses right now are struggling with
shipping they don't know how to do it
maybe you have a business selling your
unique art or maybe you're selling
antiques or maybe you're selling
anything and you need to focus on on
acquiring new customers you need to
focus on the artistic and creative side
of your business well who's going to
come around and run the back office
who's going to run the back office
who's going to make sure that all your
clients and customers are happy that all
their shipping needs are being met who's
going to make sure that you get the best
prices
who's gonna do it
not your husband because he's dead
that's why you have this business
selling pine cones you found in your
attic
that's why you go to ship station
if you go to shipstation.com
and use the code Tim Dillon
t-i-m-d-i-l-l-o-n all of the sudden you
have this effortless integration
everywhere you sell online including
Amazon Etsy eBay Shopify and more manage
every order from one simple dashboard
print shipping labels easily compare
rates and delivery times to optimize
every shipment
automate delivery
it shouldn't be driving you nuts
you should be focusing on the stuff that
makes you money finding the pine cone
and making it a Christmas tree you paint
it and you dip it in glitter and then
you sell it to people so they can give
it to their autistic children
but what you need to do there's nothing
wrong with that but what you need to do
is focus on the back orders the back
office I mean you're not you don't need
to focus on that you need to hire ship
station to do the back office while you
dip pine cones and glitter so people can
give it to their kids
because that's your job it's your
business
because your husband's dead and he left
you with a lot of debt
but people like little things
shipstation.com code Tim Dillon
shipstation.com code Tim Dylan
shipstation.com Dylan
get a 60-day free trial are you serious
go [__] your mother
60 day free trial at shipstation.com Tim
Dillon shootstation.com Tim Dillon go do
it now don't be stupid honor your
husband's memory
so I wanted to talk about this too this
is a uh this woman Becky Pringle who is
the uh
Nea the National Education Association
uh I guess she's their president
and she is and this is you know I hate I
don't want to be the one that predicts
the future here I don't want to be the
person who constantly calls out uh that
I was oh then I'm always right because I
don't want to be right you know because
the things I predict are not good all
you know usually
and I predicted a while ago that people
were gonna start having mental
breakdowns
in public and they were going to start
being rewarded for them this is a big
thing that I had this is a big
um theme that I was saying that people
that need immediate help that need to be
put into an ambulance and sent to a home
are instead going to be applauded and
Lying Eyes as a sort of visionary and a
genius and this is part of the society's
breakdown where you have some people
that are clearly unwell
but they're being celebrated
um for it and it's it's it's and the
people that are unwell it's not even
like they're doing it as a con they
don't even know they're as shocked as
anyone that they're being celebrated for
how insane they are
and they just go with it it's like
anything if you lose your mind and
people start clapping and going you're
you lead us you are our savior lead us
you go okay so this is the the head of
the National Education Association who's
clearly unwell there's no other way to
put this this is a is someone who's lost
it
and she's being applauded for it
if if someone in my organization
displayed this type of behavior I would
be incredibly concerned let's take a
look
I can hear Chief Seattle
crying out to us
urging us to remember
when you know who you are when your
mission is clear
and you burn with the inner fire of an
unbreakable will
no cold can touch your heart no Deluge
can dampen your purpose and yay you are
the stars in the darkness your light
will not be dim your purpose will drive
you in our righteous fight for freedom
because you know who you are
yes
oh no who you are yo oh yeah
our mission is clear we will advocate
for the rise of Education professionals
and we will change this world for our
students with that inner fire burning we
will never Bend we will never be broken
because we are the NBA and we will
always always do what we must
will be worthy of our students thank you
Eddie hey for all you do every day for
our babies and for our colleagues and
for your stage and for this country
our word anything
a word
I feel like did the Hitler salute at the
end
she really got into it
yeah I mean this is uh it's uh crazy
this is the type of Behavior now we're
seeing it with Fran we're seeing it here
we're seeing a type of Hysteria
that is be a certain uh a mania Manic
behavior that is being mainstreamed in
American society and applauded and
celebrated people like this and they go
this is good
um and no one knows what this woman is
talking about
she's saying these very uh deep
meaningful things but there are no
specifics anymore about anything if
you've noticed specifics have been
driven out of the national conversation
about most topics most topics we no
longer discuss anything in specifics
it's like the night is long it's like it
is what are we what are you saying
what's happening you know Fran Drescher
is you know doing her whole thing and
you go yeah but what explain to me what
this means
tell me uh word for word what we're
trying to do or trying to accomplish and
it it just feels like we're getting away
from that we're just like completely
divorced from any specifics were just
it's um
um sort of a performance
that is uh unfortunate Airbnb by the way
this is another thing that I called
Airbnb is dying Airbnb is dying for a
few reasons and I'm not even gonna go
into the fact that I'm banned from
Airbnb we all know why a lot of us do
you can watch the episode
but Airbnb exploded during the pandemic
people really wanted to kind of vacation
in other people's lives
the pandemic opened up every door of
possibility people were going maybe I
want to live in Houston
maybe I want to live
outside in Nashville and an Airbnb
allowed you
to basically manufacture the experience
of somebody who was living in that
locale
you would stay in their house you'd swim
in their pool
you would go to the coffee shop you'd
see what it would be like to live in
Charleston or Atlanta or Miami or Austin
or Phoenix
Airbnb was huge hotels were closed and
the ones that were open didn't have
Services you couldn't go to the gym
couldn't get any room service
it made a lot of sense to be by yourself
with the other people that you were
quarantining with in an Airbnb and cook
your own food and sit out uh on the
porch or on the back deck
well the world has come roaring back and
that has not been good for Airbnb
airbnb's revenues are plummeting they're
down nearly 50 percent in cities like
Phoenix and Austin
the Airbnb collapse is pretty real
and now a lot of these um and and here's
what happened with Airbnb and I'm not
going to rehash what I went through with
Airbnb except to say this the Crux of
the problem that I had with those two
women
was that they expected me to clean up
the house
after I had paid a cleaning fee in
excess of four hundred dollars
I did later threaten to kill them that
wasn't
but the the Catalyst for the whole issue
and have them killed I'm not gonna kill
them have them kill putting money behind
it and do it right but the the the issue
the Catalyst for it was why am I paying
a cleaning fee
in addition to that having to clean it
it didn't make any sense it felt strange
it felt weird
so there was that whole big war and of
course Airbnb siding uh with them which
is fine now Airbnb is collapsing
but what what had happened is Airbnb
started as like this funky cool thing
and then the rules came
you can't be outside after 10 o'clock no
visitors
we're watching you on camera if we see
anyone that we don't you know if there's
anybody's got they don't have a license
they they can't be here if they're not
checked in if they're not an official
guest
we don't want to see them airbnb's weird
and creepy we used to check in airbnbs
that we were almost certain a guy was
like they're several minutes before you
checked in it was really weird and we
also felt a few times that they had
entered the house when we weren't there
when we came back
Airbnb is a criminal organization
a lot of disgusting people are renting
their homes on Airbnb their their
voyeurs they're spying on you and
they're potentially dangerous this is
the reality this is no joke now Airbnb
has gotten away with a lot for a long
time with this and I think people have
to start understanding how vulnerable
you and your family are when you go to
an Airbnb a lot of the people who Airbnb
out their homes are sick
they're sick
they're rapists they're pedophiles
they're murderers and the reason that
they're trying to ensnare you in their
disgusting home is so that they can kill
you and your family and that's why the
the I'm not saying it's a bad business
model
I'm just saying that 50 of re the ads
have dropped 50 because 50 of people
want to live they want to live they
don't want their children to be
kidnapped by the owner of the Airbnb
who's gonna make you clean the house up
before they put you in a box
in the basement
have you ever met anyone who airbnb'd
their house let's be very honest have
you ever met these they're no no no one
will admit it no one will tell you they
do it so whoever these sick freaks are
whoever these Disturbed I've only spoken
to a few people that have their houses
on Airbnb and they're all without
exception Disturbed
they're Disturbed
I don't trust them
remember that Airbnb story we did a
while ago where somebody checked in and
it was all like satanic imagery and all
kind of these are the types of people
that are on Airbnb get up one of these
people uh one of these Airbnb hosts
we'll listen to them in their own words
because I always like to give the
opposing point of view time on my show
of course Airbnb did not do that for me
but that's okay
what I have discovered through my
limited dealings with people on Airbnb
that are renting out their homes is that
there's something not quite right with
them
there's something not quite oh oh oh oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh dear
here we are
here's what we've learned and what we've
earned after six months on Airbnb
and if you're new to the channel in July
of 2021 we bought this house
for a minute
so what this is interesting because this
is again this is a pandemic thing
we're going to realize by the end of
this
that this is this Airbnb unlike Uber
unlike some of the Great
advancements and achievements
of our business community and our Tech
Community Airbnb is an aberration it is
Unholy it is satanic it is demonic
eight and a half months and then
launched on Airbnb in November of 2021
and we documented that entire experience
and we have a weekly Vlog series about
what it's like to own an Airbnb in the
Joshua Tree area so if you're curious by
the way the two people were they were
lesbians
the two people that I had issues with an
Airbnb uh were lesbians and so it's not
them but this is what happened to Joshua
Tree a lot of people started uh coming
up with these airbnbs because everybody
wanted an escape
and Joshua tree for a certain type of
person is a great escape
and I would like to know what they
learned what did they learn what a what
is a couple like this learn when they do
Airbnb
because usually
the party line from all of these owners
is that nobody respects my house
I just opened my house and people showed
up and they started eating and living in
it
I just wanted to make a little money but
people started showing up [__] in my
toilet yeah you rented out your house
you pig
people showed up eating [__] in my house
they're all angry that people dared to
do the thing they paid to do which is
live in the [__] house
this first section is on deep cleaning
why it's necessary okay first thing they
learned yeah let's let's hear why that's
necessary
deep cleaning is a must we self-manage
our property so we come about once a
month and do a deep clean where we just
pull up all the rugs get under
everything and just really make sure
that the house is being maintained our
cleaners really let us know what's going
on in the house kind of surface level it
just allows you to look in places that
your cleaners don't normally do or and
it's your house so you know if
something's wrong something's out of
place something's going to be an issue
people are they're neat freaks but
they're they're clean freaks they're
sick there's something wrong with them I
love how they're like we self-manage and
then they're like our cleaners it's like
we do everything but clean that that's
what them Mexicans are for these white
Devils they're they're they're obsessed
with their hot they're sick do you see
in their eyes how sick they are they're
sick in the head these people and
they're obsessive about their [__]
[__]
and all they care about is like how
spotless it is keep going
so yeah here's more cleaning
the most important piece of your puzzle
when it comes to your Airbnb I cannot
stress that enough we had some issues in
the beginning trying to find a great
cleaner out here in the high desert so
you definitely have to weed through the
weeds to get to the gems it's a work in
progress always because maybe something
is out of place or whatever and it's
always communication is key when it
comes to your cleaners and if you have a
management company don't even listen to
this because they're going to be dealing
with your cleaners but if you are
managing it yourself that's like my one
of my full-time jobs is managing this
house so I'm always Michael too always
in constant communication with our
cleaners and them letting us know what's
going on and just making sure because
I'm sorry
there's a spill in the sink there's a
spill in the sink
do something
constant communication with the cleaners
lucky cleaners huh
but these are the types of people
this thing with this group of people
there's a certain group of people who
they gave their lives meaning for by
buying and renovating a house
it's strange and then opening it up for
other people to live in and they're
perpetually unhappy because they can't
afford to live in their [__] house
because they think they're this get rich
quick scheme causes these people to
renovate this house make it really nice
and then do what they never wanted to do
which is open the doors to other people
and then they become angry at their
guests
they become enraged at their guests like
they've done something wrong and they
write all these passive aggressive rules
and they tell them it's basically like
hi thanks for checking in now [__] you
and let me tell you why I'll tell you
why look in their faces they're unhappy
that other people are coming into their
home
here's the section on reviewing bad
Airbnb guests this is oh boy your
situation right here
for the first few months after you've
launched your Airbnb you're really
relying on reviews and you're terrified
of getting bad reviews right
but there's a thing called bad guests
and they'll happen and you're going to
need to speak your truth when you have
guests that didn't follow the rules that
is a huge thing that we've learned we've
had a couple bad guests and we've given
them decent Stars
as far as the review and then within the
review we say like what's up what
happened
so that other hosts know maybe we don't
want to book them or like caution when
booking them because we know we rely on
when somebody requests to book our place
we look at their reviews and so we at
first we didn't realize how important
that was but now that we've had bad
guests we realize just how important
that is and just stepping your ego out
of it that's a big lesson removing your
ego and just being like hey these are
the things that you know didn't really
line up with our with our checkout
policy just do them in a nice way our
checkout right because they want you
before you check out of an Airbnb they
want you to clean the entire house
you know they take every bottle of water
God forbid there's a bottle of water in
the refrigerator that's half drying
that's all got to get thrown out the
garbage has got to be out the entire
house has got to be cleaned even though
you paid a cleaning fee every towel's
got to be washed and fold it's like guys
what's the [__] point
that's why your the revenues are down 50
and people like her and him are going
belly up and I love that
pitch the tent
because this is what's happening these
people
are out they're being they're being
driven out of the market they're being
driven out of the market
um because they have a sick
and twisted obsession
okay with this weird curated experience
they're trying to give people that
require like when she's like you didn't
follow the rules you see you see her
face when she said that is your face
when she said that she's these are power
hungry Psychopaths that own these things
and when she said that you didn't follow
the rules what she was basically saying
is I get to boss other adults around I
get to give them bad ratings I get to
give them a report card I get to give
them a report card because they didn't
follow the rules and my [__] boxing
Joshua tree and you could you could slip
out who that you know they slip out
every now and then who they really are
it was very hard to find a cleaner in
the high desert you gotta weed through a
lot of weeds
it's very hard to find a slave in the
desert can't find any slaves in the
desert there's not enough good slaves in
the desert for me
all right let's finish up with them
nobody you don't you don't to piss
anybody off if you need a vent go to
your journal or your best friend not
Airbnb like it's Facebook you know what
I'm saying yeah
[Music]
so dogs are going to come into your
house whether you like it or not and
this is for our California and New York
friends we have gotten an abundance of
requests asking we'd love to book your
house but saw you didn't have a pet
pets we have an Esa animal if it's a
certified service animal absolutely no
problem that's fake Esa animal no
problem thank but there is some sort of
confusion and weird trickiness in the
way people use the esa animal California
we can't charge for pet fees for guest
who visits with an Esa and we are not
allowed to decline the presence of an
Esa and where it gets kind of tricky is
you're not allowed to ask for I actually
agree with them on this it's fake
because California's government is
stupid they allow people to scam You by
taking their dog to your house and
saying it's an emotional support animal
which is fake and doesn't exist it
exists only for severe autism and blind
people
everyone else that's it and I mean
severe autism meaning like you're
non-verbal or it's like five words
if you are not severely Autistic or
blind you do not get to walk around with
a dog that you like to squeeze it's all
stupid but they really can't say that
all right anyway we're not gonna go on
and on with them I they're no better or
and no worse than the other people that
are doing this but what I'm telling you
right now
is that I'm very very happy that this is
happening Airbnb because the American
public are getting smarter
they don't want to be subject to this
type of
insane treatment when you're spending
money
and to see these two
the passive aggressive anger
how you know excited they get
about rules and the checkout policy
it it takes all the fun away from owning
a house it takes all the fun away from
earning money it takes all the fun away
for
um from providing service to people and
that's why Airbnb is collapsing and the
only people that anyone who's staying in
Airbnb now is a [__] loser sorry
if you're an Airbnb now you're you're
you're a killer you're you're gonna kill
someone
because there's no person
I have not heard air am I wrong are you
guys hearing about people going to
airbnbs now no hotels it's hotels or
back [__] airbnbs what are you doing
walking into somebody's house
what the [__] that about you freak
go to a hotel let's kill this thing
let's kill this thing once and for all
let's get rid of Airbnb let's make it
illegal let's see it for what it is a
place where violent white people do
horrible things can we get rid of it now
ladies and gentlemen the American
royalty tour is on sale right now Tim
dilloncomedy.com promo code for all the
shows is fake Biz
f-a-k-e-b-i-z except for Carnegie Hall
tickets are going fast Carnegie Hall in
New York City tickets are
nycf New York Comedy Festival artist
presale code uh doing an hour stand up
comedy and then a mini podcast with Ray
comp at Carnegie Hall to see Ray comp on
stage at Carnegie Hall it's a thing that
few people will be able to say they were
able to do and it's certainly not
anything Andrew Carnegie had in mind
thank you for watching everybody we will
be back next week with a background
thank you for bearing with us